well welcome back and i am so excited
for this panel today i have two amazing
women of youtube sean already alluded a
little bit of their story but today
we're gonna be actually talking about
the seven things they learned from
reaching 100 000 subscribers let me know
in the chat do you want to reach 100 000
subscribers is that one of your goals
that you would like to do well let's
jump into this session and first off i
have lauren bateman let me tell you a
little bit about her as a childhood
cancer survivor lauren bateman knows the
importance of living in the moment
that's why at the age of 27 lauren quit
her cushy job as a research scientist to
pursue a career in music when lauren was
16 her very own mother told her sister
not to buy lauren a guitar because she
would waste it lauren decided she was
going to teach herself how to play
guitar on her own in 2010 lauren decided
to give a shot at entrepreneurship and
started teaching voice and guitar
lessons out of a spay out of a spare
bedroom
in her small apartment near boston
massachusetts she was
absolutely she had absolutely zero
teaching experience
but knew
what she needed to do to make it work
her uh her popularity as a guitar
teacher grew locally until her schedule
was bursting at the seams man if you are
a content creator who's helping people
you might feel that right now uh lauren
now operates two music schools outside
of bost outside of the boston area in
the hopes of helping students of all
ages discover the joy and happiness of
music so lauren i'm so excited that
you're here today how you doing
hey how's it going thanks for having me
oh my gosh i also i always love seeing
your setup because you always have these
little hidden gems behind you
it's my personality corner that's what i
call it
so much fun and lauren thank you so much
for being uh here at grows video live
and interacting in the app so many
people were like lauren's here so so fun
that you're actually a part of the
conference this year and i can't wait to
get into some more of uh your journey
now let me introduce nicole
nicole i also consider an amazing friend
a nicole is a parenting and soul-lining
mentor who helps women build a legacy
for themselves and their families by
showing them what is possible when they
are no longer when they no longer have
to choose between the two she has helped
millions of women in their parenting
journey and continues to redefine what
it means to be a conscious mom and a
powerhouse nicole how you doing
hey heather so happy to be here i'm
doing great thank you oh my goodness i'm
so excited that you're here and your set
looks amazing also not how you started
though right nicole
not at all this is years in the making
years in the making
so awesome well hey let's jump right
into um to today's session and i
actually asked them to submit ahead of
time uh things that they have learned
i've distilled them down into seven and
then of course i have two bonus ones for
you because they had such great tips for
you but nicole you said your one of the
uh lessons that you learned was that the
more real you are the deeper the impact
i talked a little bit about this on
stage and the last session but i'd love
to go deeper into that nicole what does
that actually mean to you and kind of
your journey on youtube with that
yeah
you know for me personally it's of
course been the journey of feeling safe
to really be my most authentic self and
it's taken years to get to that point
but what the lesson was in showing up as
the most authentic version of me is that
i build the most beautiful relationships
with people when
i am secure and safe and just being all
of me so i find that the youtube journey
has been really about building these
relationships i call them soul scribers
now right these are people who have
watched some of my videos since i was
pregnant with kai or kai was a newborn
and kai is now five and a half years old
and and these people in these
relationships follow you well beyond
youtube they follow you on other
platforms and outside of youtube and so
it's just been this beautiful evolution
of relationship building and that really
happens those deep connections happen
when you are your most authentic self
yeah and lauren did you experience this
at all because you come from a
non-traditional background when it comes
to music right it wasn't like something
you just you went to school for you
actually didn't go to school for this at
all you're really self-taught um have
you experienced that the more real you
are the more you show up as just you and
teach the things you love to teach that
you've seen um explosive growth from
that
yeah definitely i mean for me the
biggest thing like when you watch some
of my first videos you can see like i'm
really awkward and you know i'm like
stumbling over my words or i'm saying
the wrong words at the wrong time and i
think in the beginning we're so focused
on like what we should be or what we
think we should be and we focus on what
other people are doing that we forget
what we're trying to do
and you know once you get into those
videos you know 10 20 30 videos deep
more of you and your personality comes
out and that's what people want that's
what people want to connect with is is
the true you not not the version of you
that you think you should be
i love that so much lauren and man i
feel like this is like the the
explanation point to the talk that i
just gave so i love that you both have
experienced that as well now one of the
points lauren submitted was that good
content will always trump the video
quality lauren talk about your journey
in creating content over the years and
how you've really seen this be true
yeah so my first videos were just done
with the phone i didn't have a fancy
camera i didn't have the fancy lighting
i was doing a lot of things just based
off of like what i knew about filming
which was absolutely zero so i was like
well i'll just get a little tripod
actually i didn't even have a tripod i
was like putting my phone on a music
stand and it was like i was shooting
from below and weird angles all the
stuff they told you not to do yesterday
that's what i did when i started off but
you know one of my first videos that i
recorded i think it was june 2017
two years later a little over two years
later october 2019 that video was the
first video that got ranked in youtube
and it's funny because if you go back
and look at it it's like this grainy
video it's dark but people loved the
content that i was delivering so it just
goes to show in that video you know sean
talks about videos he he recorded 10
years ago still getting views that video
still gets me views and subscribers you
know four years later and it's just a
really dark grainy video but the content
is amazing and that's what people
connected with so just like you were
saying press record don't worry about
don't sweat the small stuff just press
record yeah and nicole you've
experienced this as well um some of your
most viral videos were literally you
just shooting on you know location
basically or shooting just your baby
doing certain activities talk about this
for you it really is the the the content
over the video quality of what you're
producing
oh yeah i mean you know basic camera
the window light it was enough you know
and and my audio was kind of shoddy
b-roll was interesting and i'll even say
just to add to this point it it happens
even later so i moved i moved i have a
new home and it took me a while to
figure out the lighting situation in
here and if you even go back and look a
couple months back in my vid like recent
you'll be like that that lighting isn't
quite right but i didn't let it stop me
i kept filming and i was like let me
figure out the equipment in this new
space as i go so it's always a journey
oh that's a really good one too because
you're right i mean when you move
different seasons of life you're in a
new location maybe you're normally
filming in the daytime but now you have
to film at nighttime all of those pieces
come into effect but the video quality
out trumps the actual a production
quality of what you are doing this one
was great too lauren says learn how to
do real research for videos and content
and that actually is very important to
getting to 100 000 subscribers talk
about this lauren and how you've
discovered some videos that mo people
wouldn't think would be the ones that
would actually become the famous videos
or the viral videos
yeah so you know when i first started
obviously i'm just recording and i'm
like well i should do a video on this or
i think i should do a video on this and
based on like who my audience was and
then i realized like you can actually do
research and there's seo and all the
stuff that goes behind it and then i was
like okay you know some of the things
they were talking about yesterday well
what am i competitors doing what videos
are they making that are successful so i
decided hey i'm going to research some
of these videos and i'm going to do
those same exact videos but i'm going to
do it in my way in my teaching style and
i'm going to put my own spin on it and
when i started really getting a little
bit more purposeful with the content
that i was making i noticed that that
was starting to drive views that was
starting to drive subscribers because i
was taking content that i knew would be
popular and would be good for my
audience and i was putting it in my
voice in my story and i was sharing that
with my audience and it was resonating
with them because obviously you know on
my other competitors channels with who
had success you know it was resonating
with with their audience and so i
started making those videos and pushing
out and just really paying attention to
the youtube analytics being like this
video did good why did this do good let
me do more of that this video didn't do
good why not let me not do that so i
really started paying attention to what
youtube was telling me to do versus not
do and that made a huge difference in my
channel yeah and nicole you've
experienced this as well how much
research are you doing in the types of
videos because your videos are so
specific to the woman you are trying to
reach
that's a really good question so we do
still do a lot of research around the
video topics and
and it has become more niche over time
so you know i talk about really embo
like living my life and picking topics
that are aligned with what i'm going
through in this stage and then
researching and saying where can i like
hone in and where is there a space for
me but i want to touch on this because
it's something you taught me an inner
circle and that was sometimes the video
topic ideas that are going to like blast
you off into the next level are the ones
that are super simple and you're not
even thinking about because it's right
in front of your face so like how to
burp your baby was one that i thought
like everybody knows how to burp their
baby but you're like no this is so basic
and people are actually we did the
research created that video and it's one
of my most popular videos so sometimes
we're too close to it and it's really
helpful to have community say actually
this is a good one roll with it
oh yeah i remember that time too you're
like doesn't everyone know i'm like no i
remember when i had a baby i was like
trying to figure out what do you do how
do you do this and it was all the things
so i'm so excited that um that yeah
research is such a huge part of how you
do this entire process rather than just
willy-nilly making videos that you think
you should be making now this was really
too nicole you said if you want to make
youtube sustainable make content for you
first and then your audience break that
down because
i'm sure people probably feel that like
well of course i'm going to make content
that i want to make but over time people
start asking for certain things that
could be outside of the wheelhouse of
what you're actually committed to so
talk about this a little bit and how
that has helped you get to 100 000
so very true so yeah you know a lot of
times we
we hit you know maybe semi-viral videos
or you know things that start to take
off and we're like okay let's continue
down this train
but
what i've found is that there are
chapters and phases in my life so as my
kids have grown i wouldn't always be
making videos about tummy time although
i did do a series you know and it's like
okay my kids are in a different stage
let's research and see what could work
in the phase we're in now because that's
what we're living we're playing we're
doing different activities so it aligns
with my life it's what i'm doing on a
day-to-day basis where can i capitalize
on youtube in the space i'm at in the
chapter i'm in in my actual life as
opposed to trying to
be in a space that worked at one point
but isn't necessarily aligned with how
i'm living in this moment yeah and
lauren you've actually implemented this
as well on your channel um even with the
the demographic the psychographic of
who's even watching your videos so talk
a little bit about how it really is
about making sustainable content that
you want to make not necessarily
everything your audience wants
yeah i mean in the beginning i in the
beginning uh you know because i had a
background in teaching guitar i said you
know when i started my channel i was
like i know i want to teach guitar and
who do i want to teach i want to teach
the people that i actually like teaching
so i thought about my own personal
experience as a guitar teacher and i
said you know what the favorite people
who i used to teach that it was like i
was surprised they were paying me money
to teach them because it was so much fun
said it was always people over the age
of 50 all my older students and i
absolutely loved it so i said you know
what i'm just gonna focus my channel on
older students and of course obviously
i'm gonna i'm gonna attract other people
who are younger but all the music that i
was doing it's the music i like too i
actually really like you know the led
zeppelin the neil young and all the the
older stuff the beatles i got my beatles
my george harrison guitar back here but
that was the music i really loved doing
and that's what i was passionate about
and i think that's why i got along with
that generation so i just said you know
what i'm gonna focus a lot of like my
really specific song content on this
audience and i'm gonna go wider on some
of the broader topics like strumming how
to hold a guitar like all those basic
things but my focus was really on that
older demographic the music they love
but also the music i love because then
it makes it more enjoyable for me too
and i love that you both said it really
is about the seasons like it also it's
about the people you want to reach but
also you have to have a passion for the
things you're creating we're not just
monkeys on a wheel you know we really
want to be making good monkeys on a
wheel okay we'll go with it we want to
make good content but we also want to
love the content that we're making now
both of you are incredibly focused women
both of you have careers around your
youtube channels you're not just making
youtube content both of you are running
these other businesses around what
you're doing and lauren's point was to
stay consistent create a schedule and
i'm like speaking to me i love that so
lauren how important is it to you to
stay consistent and doing that by
keeping a schedule
yeah i think my biggest downfall in the
beginning is that i wasn't consistent
you know i went back and i looked and i
was definitely not posting consistently
at all like the first couple years that
i was on on youtube so i had other stuff
you know i had a business you know you
have family life and all these other
things and then once i got consistent
about my schedule as to i do a lot of
batch recording so i'm like okay i gotta
film because i do two videos every week
and i'm like okay i'm gonna sit down and
i'm gonna film over the next couple days
all my content for like the next month
and then we go into the editing process
so for me it was really important to
schedule in time to say hey this is when
i'm going to sit down this is when i'm
going to do my content and obviously
before that point i had researched and
printed out and done all of my
organization work for how i'm going to
film these what songs i'm going to do
what lessons i'm going to do and then
obviously there's the day for the
production and the recording and then
after that it's the editing because i
found when i was trying to do like one
video a week every i always felt like
that like the monkey on the wheel as you
say you know i always felt like i was
chasing
that next video and i was it was very
stressful for me so i decreased that
stress by saying you know i'm just gonna
try and record all my videos in one day
and then i'm gonna edit them out and
that helped just relieve a lot of stress
for me and if something came up in life
that was okay because like i already
have recorded all the content i just
needed to edit it and and that helps so
much so if you don't have a schedule yet
just pick one day a week that you're
gonna commit to your channel and it
makes a huge difference yeah and nicole
i'm sure so many people can relate to
you know just your seasons of life i
don't think anyone comes to youtube and
says you know what i have nothing to do
i should start a youtube channel no
they're coming to youtube and they're
like i'm already an entrepreneur i'm
already you know running a family i'm
you know doing all the things
and i also want to do youtube that was
where you came in the and i also want to
do youtube so talk about what does your
schedule look like now in creating your
content how important is it to have a
schedule around what you're creating
it's a really good question so i'm i'm
slightly different i will say i started
with a schedule and it was really
important to me to get into a groove
initially um but being a mama to two
young ones my youngest one is 10 months
now and having a husband who's also an
entrepreneur there's a lot of give and
take and flexibility and so sticking to
a specific schedule has been a bit
challenging but i'm five years in now
and i just know that i'm committed and
if you go back and you look at my
youtube channel i'm still consistent i
still get the content out so i trust
myself that if it means i gotta film at
10 o'clock at night or on a day i wasn't
planning like i will get it done but it
was important to have structure around
me in the beginning to get into that
routine and have it be muscle memory
before i could say all right we're in a
season where we need more flexibility
you can be adaptable and i know that
you're just committed to this mission
you're going to figure it out oh that's
really good too yeah it changes as you
get more comfortable in front of the
camera as you get more comfortable and
like you said just being committed to
making the content the i will until i
will get this done i will figure this
out uh so number seven is uh nicole you
said there will be sharp ups and sharp
downs in this journey i think people
need to hear that i think that you know
especially when you're at a conference
like this and you're seeing some amazing
successful women like you two it's like
dang how did they get there it must have
been just luck right it's all just luck
so uh talk about those sharp ups and
those sharp downs on the journey nicole
yeah this has been huge for me because
it's so easy to get stuck in the very
moment or like that 30-day
stats right where it's like oh things
look down you know your subscriber
counts down your views are down and
especially in the beginning it's easy to
become discouraged with that and think
like okay well nothing i'm doing is
working should i just call it like this
clearly isn't working out for me and i
had a moment about a year ago where i
was going through that was like month
after month i couldn't figure out how to
get things back on track i just seemed
to be in this slide and then i did
myself a favor and i clicked
lifetime on our stats right where it
breaks down like your stats over your
entire lifetime and at that time it had
been about four years on youtube
and it was this beautiful moment this
epiphany of like it is up and down on
the way up when you pan out you see that
your trajectory is in fact heading in
the right direction you are moving you
are making gains but if you zoom in you
will see this
on your statistics it looks up it looks
down and in the moment when things are
sliding it just feels like everything is
falling apart but i want you to be able
to pan out and look at the big vision
and if you're just starting can you
trust that this is a minor dip and an
otherwise upward trend so just staying
committed to your mission and your
vision and keep moving
yeah wow what a great insight to
actually pan out and see the whole
picture uh we did that here at think
media you know about a year
two years ago now we were in a downward
slump and we were like man what is
happening and we pulled out the numbers
and we're like oh actually we're doing
just fine it's okay it just this is kind
of the cycle of life there are there's
spring there's summer there's winter and
there's fall how about you lauren have
you experienced kind of those big ups
those big downs in this journey even
just as an entrepreneur building
businesses and trying to build your
youtube channel at the same time
yeah i think that's i think that's just
the cycle of life there's there's highs
and there's lows and i remember
specifically um after you know the first
kind of covet after the shutdowns you
know everyone was home so everyone was
watching youtube everyone was all of a
sudden learning trying to learn guitar
so you know everything was really up in
you know march april may of 2020 i think
for a lot of youtubers and my adsense
was like really killing it at that point
and then i remember i posted in in the
vra you know facebook group and i i
think it was august it was this time of
year because august is summer this is
kind of like the slow time of year in
general for like music lessons even for
a brick and mortar business and i
remember being really disappointed i was
like man i was like i was doing so well
and now everyone's outside it's not it's
not going so great i remember being like
really down on myself and being like
that was it that was like that was like
my ride was was right there uh and then
it was just the cycle the fall came
around and you know christmas season
people get new guitars and stuff and
then all of a sudden everything shot
back up again so i think it's also
understanding the cycle of your business
so i know as a music teacher summer
tends to be that downward slump anyway
so i should expect things to pick up you
know as we get closer to christmas new
year's etc yeah and man i that was so
poignant what you said as a business
owner as a youtuber you should just know
that it's not always going to be up that
there's going to be ups there's going to
be downs because there's seasons to
business there's a reason that there is
an entire black friday sale crazy
christmas shopping all of those things
in actual retail stores because they are
anticipating that you're gonna buy stuff
for christmas whereas in the summer
there's not as much so it's really great
inside ladies all right we're gonna get
into some bonus
uh points that you guys have but if you
like content like this i just have to do
a plug because we do interviews like
this on our podcast make sure you're
subscribed to the think media podcast
because we bring on different industry
experts and amazing students just like
lauren and just like nicole and we
interview them and we go deeper into
into different topics like how are you
getting brand deals and how are you
making money with beyond your adsense or
how are you fighting past the imposter
syndrome
as you are reaching these different
milestones we talk all about that on the
think media podcast so make sure that
you subscribe to that i hope that every
single person that's at this conference
at least subscribes to the podcast so
that you can continue hearing
conversations like this okay uh let's
see lauren had a great insight which was
interact with your audience and build
community how important has that been on
your journey to one hundred thousand
lauren
yeah i mean it's it's so important i
think to connect with people and that's
why you know i'm here in the conference
i'm here in the chat and and talking
with people because people want to get
to know you and you know reaching out
just responding to those comments the
biggest thing that i get from a lot of
people even people who go and buy my
guitar course they send me emails all
the time like i was so impressed that
you respond to every single comment that
or that i actually got a response from
you on a comment they said that really
impressed me and that's what actually
made me go and purchase your product so
make sure to reach out get those
connections you know i have a private
facebook group but i do have like a free
facebook group and i'm in there i'm
talking to people and you know we're
sharing stuff about guitar but you know
when i went to iceland in july i'm
sharing my journey what i'm doing in
life with people and they're so excited
to hear about that they want to be a
part of your life and get to know you so
don't be afraid to share other parts of
yourself with your audience it's going
to make that connection stronger yeah
nicole you've really experienced by
being so in tune with your community
these amazing opportunities to be able
to create other products for them high
level products masterminds being able to
go deeper in exactly what they want
nicole is a product on how to feed your
baby i mean you wouldn't know that
nicole unless you were really deep in
your community how has this experience
allowed you by being in community how
did you get those ah-has to know i need
to create this for her next how did you
follow that journey
i love that question yeah it you know
it's a lot of what lauren said and just
building relationship with people you
know so inviting them into other spaces
off of youtube so whether it's an email
i have people respond to emails that go
out and it's just been this journey of
building relationships and understanding
what other women other mamas are walking
through and it's been huge for me in
terms of like what what would benefit my
community what should i create next and
being in conversation with them and also
allowing myself to evolve you know the
products and the things that i am
offering as eyeball and as my community
evolves too so relationship building
responding to comments inviting them
into your world being open to share more
of who you are and the journey you're on
has been ginormous in in my path to
building a business yeah and i want to
just make it very clear neither of you
have like teams of 20 around you
answering all your comments and sending
your emails is that correct lauren this
is you one on one in your community
right
yes yes i mean in the beginning i have
some some help now because it is getting
but i'm still in there like i'm still in
there all those personal technical
questions that's me and you know a lot
of times if people send me emails it's
me i'm it's still in the trenches a lot
only because i love hearing from the
community because they tell me what they
want lauren can you do a video on this
and i'm like you know what that's
actually a really good idea and i did a
video recently on a suggestion that
someone had made and it was like one of
my top videos so listen
to your audience that's the point of
interaction because that i i don't do a
lot of research anymore because people
just keep telling me what they want me
to do my content on so be in there
interact listen
that is amazing and exactly the point i
wanted to make was that it is i make it
a point to make sure that i am still
engaged with our community because when
you start losing touch you'll see
creators like this they start to lose
touch with their actual audience and
they start creating other content and
then they're like why isn't it working
because they have to be actively engaged
because this is the community you get to
create i mean this is how i look at it
as you just heard my story uh that i
wanted to be people people pleaser now
it's almost it's the complete opposite
now i'm like i only want to be around
people that i like like i want to be in
community with people that get what i'm
doing and geek out about the things that
i'm doing and it's so much fun and
lastly you know uh sean said it last
night i thought it was so great and i
want nicole to end with this but he said
you know it's not like you can take the
silver play button to the bank i know
that both of you have reached over 100
000 subscribers you both have those
silver play buttons in the background
you've reached this milestone on youtube
but really you wake up the next day and
you're still the same girl right but
nicole had such a great point i want to
end on this one she said you will be
better for this journey nicole close
this out by telling us a little bit
about why that was something that helped
you on your journey to one hundred
thousand
yeah you know
it's like it's beyond the numbers it's
beyond the views it's beyond
everything that the accolades and the
awards it's like who do you want to be
on the other side of this i've gained so
much more intangible things like the
skill sets my ability to communicate my
ability to connect with other women who
are
in motherhood and going through the same
things that i am i i'm just a completely
different woman than when i started five
years ago and i wouldn't trade the ups
and the downs or this path to be here
for anything you know it's like i love
the silver play button i love what i've
created but ultimately this is the
legacy of me being courageous me trying
new things me following my soul and what
lights me up
and and having an impact and so
no matter what numbers you reach what
accolades you have brand deals
sponsorships it's all beautiful it's all
the cherry on top
but you can't lose by starting this you
will be better on the other side of this
journey
wow thank you so much for that nicole
and i so feel that in exactly what
you're creating and what lauren's
creating i want to thank both of you um
just for being women who said yes for
stepping up stepping out grabbing the
camera pressing record being leaders in
your community being so gracious with
your time today to come on and share a
little bit about your experience i know
both of you are very focused women and
so just giving your time to us today at
this conference is a huge blessing so
thank you for being leaders i'm so glad
that we're connected i love that we're
friends also in real life because it
brings me so much joy so lauren where
can they go if people want to find out
more and follow your journey obviously
you're inside of video ranking academy
obviously you're here at the conference
but if they want to connect with you
where can they go
yeah i mean i'm on pretty active on
instagram at the lauren bateman um and
my website is laurenbateman.com that's
my guitar teaching website so you can
always contact me through the contact
form there
amazing and nicole where can they go if
they want to go deeper with you
i am nicole amber on facebook instagram
and youtube so and my website is also
nicole amber.com awesome well hey share
your aha moment in the chat below give
it up round of applause for lauren and
for nicole thank you ladies for your
time today